hey everyone i'm lucy joined by tomorrow
hussein
hi and dave klein great
and uh recently dave got to go hands-on
a little bit of an extra hands-on with
eldon ring um beyond where the close
network test ended which is very
exciting so tam and i are going to quiz
him about all the new stuff he got to
play and see how the game is shaping up
ahead of the february 25th release date
so
tammy and i both played
the network test
yeah um pretty extensively but dave what
did you get to play that was different
so um
firstly it's the same areas the network
test at first limb graves pretty much
your starting area but
they did change things which we can talk
about a little bit and then i got to
play into the stormville castle the area
south of limgrave and then a little
beyond stormville castle so i got to hit
up godric say hi to him
ask him why it was grafted you know that
sort of thing
perfect i mean like you you kind of
mentioned it there that things have
changed and i think
that's the stuff that i kind of want to
ask about before we get into the new
stuff because obviously the the network
test is so that from can get it in front
of players maybe tweak things i think in
particular people were talking about
maybe
spirit ashes the uh the kind of
wolves or you know the the sort of
the summons i guess if you want to call
them that felt a little bit overpowered
um i'm very intrigued to see um what
they would have changed uh so what what
leapt out at you
so i decided for my first three hours
basically to just replay everything from
the network test because i knew i could
do that fast just to level up and give
myself a chance to play more in a way
uh so some of the bosses were slightly
different like some of them actually had
a larger move set than they did in the
network set test which was interesting
like the smaller dungeon bosses
um also some of the bosses were
different not many but a couple where i
was like oh i thought this would boss
would be there
it's a different boss
uh the drops were totally different
which is something that i think we were
suspecting um like there wasn't as much
overpowered gear in the beginning as an
example
um and then honestly market was a little
easier to me than he was in the network
test and the spirit ashes were nerfed
for sure um i didn't really use them
that much in the network test because i
wanted to see if i could beat the bosses
solo i use them a little bit more here
um
they did like
no damage at all to the bosses they
really just helped
uh distract them really more than
anything although
you can level them up so that's
something i never did i never found the
person to do that but i did find
materials to allow you to level them up
so
so that's the thing the boss stuff can
you are you allowed to talk about what
the new bosses are do and what all the
changes were they do you feel like
they're changes because
um
they're narratively more relevant to
what the final game is going to be or is
it a case of they're experimenting with
different bosses now just to see and
tune and that kind of because sometimes
they they'll chuck in a boss that is
clearly not meant to be there just to
see
mechanically if it's tuned properly and
other times it's like all right now
we're going to put in the bus here
because this is where the boss will be
for the narrative and characterization
the boss changes in terms of the
locations weren't that different they
were just a little bit and it wasn't it
didn't feel like a narrative thing to me
i'm guessing they were just playing
around with it um because i did find one
of them in a different spot and he
wasn't any harder it was just like oh
okay i know this one and now he's here
uh actually one of the ones they
replaced was way more difficult where i
was like whoa uh that's different i
think with market um
it might be a case of just like leveling
and all that where i felt more prepared
weirdly even though i i don't know if i
was as high of a level this time around
and it could also just be because now i
know his moveset from having played the
network test
but he definitely didn't pose as nearly
as much of a challenge as the network
test where i was relieved to have beaten
him in the network test
that's not to say the bosses are
any easier for people wondering like
there was a boss early on that i thought
that had a more of much more expanded
moves that was like this boss is
challenging now they were really easy
before
um so yeah it's not it's it feels very
standard souls to me in terms of
difficulty like nothing stood out to me
is like extremely difficult like more so
than normal nothing stood out to me is
way too easy and architecturally like
did did the was was the air early area
lynn graves still mostly the same like
no news uh mini dungeons or anything
like that popping up or any more like
unexpected new enemies that we haven't
seen before
as far as i could tell lim grave was the
exact same other than that there are no
walls blocking you from going where you
want to go which is nice yeah that's
good i mean like i maybe i didn't
explore deep enough because for me lim
gray was like i know this i'm gonna do
everything as fast as i can just so i
can move on to new stuff
so i wasn't really looking into the
nitty-gritty details but everything
seemed relatively the same i'll say the
the dragon statue um on the island that
you could find the network test
that was a little more expanded i don't
want to ruin too much it's not like
there's not that much more there's just
slightly more you can get there than in
the network test in the network test if
you got the dragon heart for being the
dragon you can take it to that island
and get something for it it's still
similar it just has a little more yeah
usage but that's about it that's the
only thing i noticed i i don't i just
don't want to spoil too much
i want to reveal things but without
being too spoilery you know
i mean honestly i'm glad you
i mean i'm i'm glad that you're kind of
doing it that way i know a lot of people
watching will be glad as well because
it's one of those games where
a lot of the joy from games are is the
discovery along the way yeah it's also
really cool to hear that like
i don't know how you guys are feeling
but you know when you've played a little
section of a game before when it comes
to final release it's like i don't have
to play all that again but the fact that
stuff has moved and changed is exciting
to me and i think as well you kind of
approach it with the confidence of i've
played some of this before like i know
basically how
characters move how it all works and now
i can just approach it my own way so
dave when you did this latest
play through
which class did you pick did you do
anything differently
okay i'm going to look up the name of
the class real quick because i chose a
class that wasn't in the network test
so i chose the vagabond
that's a new class so
uh the classes by the way and i i think
i can say this that you could choose at
least for me were vagabond warrior hero
bandit astrologer prophet samurai
prisoner confessor and wretch
wretch is the level one character so
they're they do have one of those back
which is nice
um but on vagabonds
yeah at least as far as we know yeah
uh vagabond was uh basically your night
class and i i typically bounce between a
dex build and a strength build for what
i like to play and vagabond was a bit
more of a strength type of build so
that's what i ended up choosing for this
test
whereas actually when i did the network
test i did the dex build so i kind of
changed it up a little bit
what was what was that class like then
um in terms of special unique abilities
and general performance because i went
with the bloody wolf originally um yeah
and it felt and that's a dex build as
well um and that felt pretty good but i
generally
um gravitate towards the the knight type
as well um and use strength
yeah you probably like vagabond then
yeah um
i mean like honestly it starts with the
long sword it didn't start with a heavy
weapon which i think the lone wolf does
yeah um so i
started with just a normal long sword
but it was pretty easy to level into
that strength build i think it starts
with a little more dexterity than the
lone wolf so maybe the lone wolf is more
of a pure strength build but i like
having a bit of quality i guess and i
just wanted to try something new
but i mean pretty early on i found a
heavy weapon that i decided to switch to
because it did a good job um stunning
enemies and i was like this is nice i'm
switching to this so i started using
that instead and going pretty full on
strength build okay well you mentioned
new stuff there let's get into the new
stuff that you got to play so you went
all the way up to stormville
godric
how did that go and then where did you
go after that
yeah so this is something that i was
thinking about as a good analogy for
people who haven't played as far as
stormville goes in a way
if people are wondering how the open
world works for um eldon ring it's like
imagine playing demon souls
but instead of having your step your hub
and then you warp into boletaria you
warp into latria it's almost like hey
i'm going to roam into a world and i
happen upon bolitaria happen upon
um
latria whatever area although i guess
honestly i guess the size-wise it's a
little more comparable to as far as
stormville goes it's a little more
comparable to like cathedral of the deep
from dark souls 3 or maybe irithyll
okay like maybe about that size if
slightly bigger than that so maybe
irithyll like a slightly larger type of
major area like that
and it feels very very classic souls in
the sense of and bloodborne and the
sense of like you can't use your your
horse there
or your steed um
it's very like interwoven dungeons like
there are a couple major paths and
multiple paths where i found like oh
this is where they we back into each
other this is ways that they connect or
don't connect and where you can go
around
uh it was a very fun classic from
software experience going into that
i definitely didn't finish exploring
stormville i started to run out of time
and was like okay i need to just find
godric and try to beat him
so i kind of just bum rushed it to the
end
aft the
later mark of my time in stormville but
there's a lot there it's um
it was a nice classic from experience
and definitely outside of whatever you
feel about the open world
once you get into that you'll be like
this is it i'm back into a classic from
experience
did it have mini buses in stormville as
well or is it just like you explore up
until you reach the main bus and then
you're done
so if you recall the many armed key
bearer whatever from the the network
test as everyone was calling it um i
think they're called scions for real or
something similar to that
there there was one of those that i
found that i think was actually in one
of the trailers but
i was kind of under leveled when i first
got to stormville and when i started
attacking it i didn't have to fight it i
just chose to and i realized i was doing
like
mix of damage to it and it would kill me
in like two hits
so i never came back to try to kill it
but it was just kind of in the middle of
the dungeon otherwise i i didn't find
any mini bosses but there might be some
other ones that i just didn't happen
upon
i found one end piece with two npcs the
one that you find
um in the network test that's like
handling the gate and then the one that
was in the trailer so i don't feel like
i'm spoiling anything saying that yeah
any any kind of indication i assume
it's going to be the same but like quest
progression is there
does it did you get any kind of like
experience with that did multiple
characters or did one character pop up
in multiple places because the originals
from software approaches you talk to a
character
over time that character moves and then
you know there's different circumstances
that's how you progress their quest is
it do you feel like it's the same
because obviously that's a
contentious way to do um
uh
arc arc progression
yeah
so as far as the main quest goes melano
changes and does some says some
different things with there's some
progression there but that's like main
story
um there were some side quests that i
found
but i didn't
i know there was quest progression for
sir because i either messed up or
something bad definitely happens in some
instances i don't know which and i just
don't want to spoil it what it was
specifically but there there is some of
that quest progression with npcs for
sure okay and i don't know how many
branches there are i either messed up or
there was one branch i don't know
but yeah there's some press uh quest
progression definitely i think for me
it's interesting that they're sticking
to their guns and still having that kind
of quest progression in their style
because obviously that's something that
mo even people who play from software
games start to finish will often not
interact with the quest progression part
of
it which is uh good on them for sticking
with that sticking to their guns yeah
i i actually like it so i'm glad that
they're doing that although it's hard
for uh for finding lore because that's
like okay oh god did i miss something
that i
but
uh something else interesting too that i
found while playing this was that when
we played the network test all the
dungeons were pretty small they felt
almost like chalice dungeons from
bloodborne
outside of the main legacy dungeon that
we really didn't get to play
um i did happen upon a dungeon that game
informer talked about in their article
um
that is much bigger that's not a legacy
dungeon that's like i'd say like a more
medium-sized dungeon that feels like a
very classic from software dungeon
experience that didn't feel as much like
a chalice dungeon and i wasn't expecting
it too i was like i'll just like knock
this out really quick because i was just
trying to kind of like level up a bit
and find some things before i returned
to stormville to tackle it a second time
and uh it just kept on going it's like
oh this is actually big it kind of
surprised me uh but in a good way
so that's definitely worth noting
because i think i could see at least
myself i was a little disappointed by
some of the dungeons and that they all
felt so small
and then finding that like oh wow okay
there really is a range here where
there's going to be very mini dungeons
medium-sized ones this one was a little
bit bigger
uh that was interesting
do you think that kind of helps with the
co-op part of it because this is a game
that i feel like more people are going
to play in co-op than any previous game
um do you think that having
do you see yourself doing more of that
kind of open world stuff in co-op um or
do you feel like you're gonna
solitary play it again
this is
hard for me to say because i like
tackling these games solo i never play
them co-op unless i'm doing like stuff
with friends for videos um i'm
definitely tackling it solo that's just
how i like playing these games yeah i i
from the stuff that i played in network
test i think i'm the same where i'd play
solo but i think i'm more inclined to
jump into people's games now and do some
of the not invasion but like you know
the co-op stuff and if there's people
that i feel like this is the game where
if you have always had an interest in
souls games but always never quite
clicked with you um this is the game
where you could probably
grab a couple friends and explore the
open world together and i think of it as
like breath of the wild but co-op in a
lot of ways
yeah but uh yeah so that could be
interesting and and because of that i
think i like the idea of having bigger
dungeons that aren't main dungeons
because it would wear thin if you were
doing the stuff co-op and every dungeon
took like five minutes to do yeah
yeah you need to have bigger spaces
it was a concern i had before going into
this honestly uh for myself and then it
was kind of a welcome relief when i
found that where i was like okay this is
nice that there are some different sizes
uh there are definitely some cool
mysteries i found too which is awesome
where i'm like i don't know how to do
this this is really cool i want to find
out like um that trailer where there's
the thing walking that had the bell and
underneath and the church on top yeah
i found it
i don't know what to do i have this like
oh this is great i found it what the
hell do i do yeah it's fun to have those
mysteries lingering over so it's cool
that there's a lot of that too there's a
lot of intriguing mystery still yeah was
that in the network test i remember no
it was uh it was in a different area so
so i happened upon it this time playing
it
and yeah i was just like oh sick it's
like there it is anything else you can
tell us about the new areas you got to
see
yeah uh okay so godric uh i did fight
him and i think it took me about five
attempts to beat him um
so i had the lowest level spirit ash and
i decided to use it uh for one of mine
just to help distract him and it did a
good job and then
i i didn't find him any more difficult
than a standard souls boss personally um
but it's not like he was easy it's just
that
you know he feels like a pretty standard
soul's boss to me in a lot of ways and
then he has a second form
uh which i don't want to spoil too much
about even though i think everyone kind
of knows from the trailer what it's
going to be like but um
is it
is there anything you can say about like
the general approach to fighting him
because like you look at him and
obviously most souls players are going
to be like
try and circle strafe get behind him and
and that kind of stuff because but then
you know
that is the general approach for most
enemies or bosses that look the way
godric does but yeah and from software
has had an awareness of that stuff like
and easy ones like dark souls 2 flexer
century it's like you they designed that
boss very much to stop people from doing
that yeah you get a sense of their
awareness for for like uh kind of
subverting expectation or even forcing
people into doing other things that they
would traditionally not
so for godric specifically i i guess i
found that i kind of figured out his
moveset early on and it was kind of like
okay this is the move where i need to
get away and dodge a bunch of times and
then he's gonna either run in at me or
stay away okay and then i it felt very
classic i didn't feel like it subverted
my expectations too much there was a
boss early on
that i found um so
uh eldon ring has something very similar
to um
the the keystones from dark souls 2
where
uh ferris's keys uh where basically like
you have special unlockable areas with
keys that are limited that you run out
of
the legacy dungeons had areas like this
i actually found um a gowl or gull the
one if you remember that area for the
network test i found one of those that
was locked away by the one of those
things
and there's another one early on that i
found where there was a boss
at the bottom
that was very bloodborne-esque in a lot
of ways was like this is weird
i
i had to go back like
five times after leveling up a bunch and
leveling up my weapons to try to tackle
him again because i really wanted to
beat him and when i finally did i still
wasn't sure that i knew his moveset
really i was like i don't i feel like i
just lucked out of beating this guy i
like he was so weird the way he moved
and i was like i think i kind of get it
and then he do something like i don't
get it i don't know
so uh there is some of that it's just
godric specifically didn't throw me off
too much but there was some of that
that's good yeah my concern is
the reason i love sakura is because
almost none of the the classic souls
approaches work on any of it and my
concern was like oh we're gonna get the
get in the ass and clap them cheeks boss
and then we're gonna get the um
you know like run away for a minute and
then run in hit do a strike or run away
so it sounds like they've they're mixing
things up a bit which is good
yeah i think gadget
might hit your concerns a little bit at
least for me and i'd assume for you
it'll feel very classic honestly i think
margaret gave me a bigger challenge than
godric uh my first time fighting
margaret yeah was aggressive
so yeah because margaret was so
aggressive and even when he tried to
stay away he'd still like sometimes do
something like
screw you margaret
but yeah godric wasn't so bad for me but
um
yeah like there are some bosses i found
that were like this is more bloodborney
and more weird and if you play
bloodborne you're kind of familiar in a
way but it's still like you know those
ones get weird sometimes you're like
okay this is different this is weird i
don't know what limit it has and what
it's going to use with that limb
uh there were some really cool enemies i
found too so i was able to play a little
bit past godric as well and
i found there are multiple type of
archeries by the way i don't want to
spoil what's in any of them but there's
different sizes and each size has a
different type of treat
um with it or
enemy associated with it
um
something i can also say i think is that
gadrik for beating him you do get the
boss soul sort of thing where you can
get weapons okay uh if you find the
right character
with the juicy lore descriptions on
those as well uh
and uh i did find
well this is in the trailer i i did find
a great rune
i don't want to say where or how i found
it but i did manage to find a great rune
those also have interesting status
effects and you can actually use those
on your character
for the most part the area past godric i
i defeated him i played for seven hours
about i've defeated him with 30 minutes
left to spare so that point i was kind
of just like in panic mode of like i
need to see everything i can so i was
just like got on my horse
and just started like running through
everything just to be like let me see as
many sights and sounds as i can see
beyond him
um the area afterward does change up it
doesn't look like lim grave so if
anyone's concerned about everything
looking like limb grave it doesn't um
which is nice
uh there were definitely
uh it was like more of a swampy marsh
sort of area in a way but we're back at
the swamps i was gonna say it wasn't
possible though uh yet yet uh who i know
there are poisonous swamps this one
wasn't yet but
uh but it was it was cool it was a cool
area it was different i didn't get a
chance to explore it too much
but and i could tell they're like again
there's like a lot of things whereas
like there's probably this cool dungeon
there there's probably a cool secret
there that i wasn't really able to
explore into
the area south of limb grave that you
could i think honestly before you go to
stormville you're supposed to go to the
area south of limb grave i think that's
logically what you're supposed to do
that i explored a little more and there
are a bunch of churches with um
important things
basically there's ways that you can
upgrade your estes flasks and you
probably want to do that before you go
into stormville interesting all right um
so after all this time
with the game both network tests and
this new hands-on we're a couple weeks
out uh
is there anything about elder ring that
kind of has you worried as a long-term
uh fromsoft fan
because it is a very big departure from
my personal concern and this is just for
me is that the open world will detract a
bit from how much i love their typical
interconnected
style worlds where like bloodborne i
just love
when you like wrap around yharnam and
you're like oh my god this connects all
the way back here and how cool is that
and while the legacy dungeons do have
that within it
it was nice for me with bloodborne that
the entire world felt that way or dark
souls won the entire world felt that way
so i'm a little worried about that for
myself but it's definitely
nice i always like when from software
tries something different and it's nice
to see them trying something different
and like my one of my biggest concerns
was the smaller dungeons
and finding this like larger just
regular dungeon was like okay they kind
of my concern has been addressed
in that regard
but yeah i think that that's it and it's
just very personal to me i know some
people are going to be like great i love
that they're just doing open the fact
that you can just skip stormville and go
to a different area because it's too
hard or you just want to explore
something else i'm sure some people will
absolutely love that aspect
perfect well dave thank you so much uh
elden ring is coming out february 25th
it's not long to wait at all we are
gonna have so much coverage up on
gamespot so make sure you like this
video and subscribe time where can
people find you you find me on twitter h
dave
the dave klein
go to go to dave control live on youtube
as well because dave's got a lot of good
um
stuff there yeah thank you and i'm on
twitter at lucy james games and we'll
see you next time bye thanks
[Music]
you